a cpac was mostly worthless
the second day uh was a complete
throwaway
nothing worth covering happened on the
second day saturday
which is good because i was in bed with
a fever from my second coronavirus
vaccine dose
i wouldn't have been able to cover any
of it anyway fortunately in a sense
there was nothing worth covering but one
theme that sort of wound its way
throughout friday and saturday
and sunday is that cpac attendees
were unwilling to accept that donald
trump
lost we are what just a few days
short of form december january february
march
were days from being four months beyond
the election which joe biden easily won
more easily than the margin by which
trump won in 2016
and cpac speakers i guess because
they're still
sort of cow towing to trump placating
trump
will not admit that trump simply lost
let's go through some examples
here is tom fitton from judicial watch
this is one bizarre guy with some kooky
ideas
saying trump had the votes on election
day but
vote totals changed as ballots were
counted can you
imagine take a listen on election day
president trump had the votes to win the
presidency
these vote totals were changed because
of unprecedented and extraordinary
counting
after election day now in a literal
sense
what tom fitton says is true
votes that were cast by election day
were counted after election day legally
as always happens with absentee ballots
and as those votes were counted the
results changed
yet that is in a technical sense it is
true
he wants you to believe something
illegal happened of course it didn't
then larry kudlow donald trump's former
economic advisor talking about polling
from last october
he's put we have ballots that we counted
now
you talk about polling beforehand but
larry kudlow
is talking about polling from before the
election comments on that i was
interested last october
a gallup poll said 56 percent of
americans
believed at that time that they were
better off
than they were four years ago despite
the fact that they had been in the
pandemic they still believed
that they were better off that's a trump
thing
that's a trump thing
and then josh hawley gets a standing
ovation
after reminding the crowd that he
voted not to certify the election
results on january 6th
this was part of what incited the
violent riot
and the crowd gives josh hawley a
standing ovation you know on january the
6th
i objected during the electoral college
certification maybe you heard about it
i did i stood up
uh i i guess the crowd believes that
they are being
principled in some way by
giving josh hawley this standing ovation
for an action holly's action much like
ted cruz and others
that melded with rudy giuliani's trial
by combat thing and all this other stuff
and of course
trump's speech saying let's go to the
capitol and led to a riot the crowd
cheering it then matt schlapp who runs
the american conservative union that's
the organization that
organizes cpac saying that what happened
in november
it was an unconstitutional power grab
in leaving cpac it would be do all you
can
to any member that we have any influence
over to explain to them that it's
unacceptable
to have this unconstitutional power grab
on elections
so that what we saw this election will
be what you will see
every single election and we have to
fight it now
it wasn't an unconstitutional power grab
it was that joe biden won
they still can't accept it and why
should they trump still hasn't accepted
that hillary got more votes than him in
2016. it's been five
years and trump doesn't accept those
results
so of course they're not going to accept
the results from almost four months ago
since they think they won they won't be
changing their strategy either
and here's house minority leader gives
me great pleasure to say minority leader
kevin mccarthy
laying out the plan listen we're going
to continue to do exactly what we did in
the last election
okay i mean if you think you won i guess
you do the same thing
and uh they are also as we talked about
earlier in the show
planning to suppress more votes they're
already scheming to do it
we gave you a report earlier in the show
about 253
different bills and measures to suppress
voting
across 43 states republicans believe
they won
i guess certainly they don't want to
change their strategy
but they didn't suppress enough votes
and that's what they're going to try to
do
now one last hilarious moment this is
this is my favorite
right side broadcasting is one of these
online based right-wing
channels i don't think they're as big as
newsmax in oan
but they're big enough that they're
worried about getting sued and
cpac was rife with anti-science
discussions related to covid
and rife with anti-fact discussions
related to the election
right side broadcasting during a cpac
panel discussion
about the election cut away to read one
of the funniest disclaimers i've ever
heard to try to protect themselves from
legal liability
three different states forty two
thousand votes forty five thousand votes
something like that and we would have
had an electoral college
uh vote of 269 to 269. there's a lot of
sensitive topics
we want everyone to do your own research
in regards to what they're
talking about in this discussion right
now anything with the election or
anything like that
so uh it's important to do your own
research i know there's several outlets
here that are able to
completely uh broadcast all of this
content
uh for you with any disclaimer at all
but unfortunately here at right side
broadcasting we must
jump in here and put a small disclosure
that
we want you to do your own research and
it's very important that we do that yeah
absolutely just quickly although we are
broadcasting these speakers we want to
provide you with that
it does not mean that we necessarily
believe or support
all of their beliefs of every single
speak speaker talking today so make sure
that you research everything you talk to
your healthcare position
physicians whether it's regarding covid
or medical information and
if it's election related just look it up
and look everything up and we are just
not endorsing any speakers for the event
again we are simply
broadcasting these speakers talk to your
health care physicians
there's so many election lies and so
many bogus medical claims being made at
cpac
that right side broadcasting has to cut
away
and issue this absolute gold disclaimer
and at one point uh they also
um they interrupted mike lindell from my
pillow during an interview i'm not even
going to play it because it's so stupid
but they interrupted and said uh you
know we have to be really careful mike
because we could lose our entire thing
and mike lindell said oh oh oh
you can find that clip if you want like
an extra bonus clip
but this is where my coverage of cpac
ends we're going to take a quick break
we'll do more vaccine stuff after the
break and many more things glad you're
with us on this first
show in march 2021